hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to my finishing playthrough
of slender how bit yeah it's been a
while since I played this one and I only
played this one once before so I thought
you know since people like my Center
ones I feel like it I deserve alright
I'm obligated to finish the old ones
that plagued me before so this one I
need to complete a poem so I know the
map now Dom I'm a glancing downward
totally not cheating or anything right
wait wait here so he's looking at me
judging me as I complete this totes mix
groats legitimately this one exit oh
crap I'm going the wrong way again I
don't even know where I am where am I
crane my neck oh so not suspiciously oh
hey wait is the donater boy oh look at
it guys
ok so hello am i this Bob doesn't help
me at all ok right
all right screw oh how are you look at
that eats you alive ok it started and I
have no idea where I am because
everything seems to be wrong oh yeah
here wait how would you like to you
anyway ok so listen there's a hallway on
this map called the you mad bro hallway
which probably probably the bad sign
I'm guessing Slendy eat your face off on
I don't know where I'm going ah oh no no
either let's see I don't remember there
being so many donated pictures in this
game it's a line there's like nothing
but then again in this game I kind of
effed up a lot and kind of just went
around in circles over and over and over
again so I have no idea if I'm going the
right way or the wrong way but we've
been luck
okay all right Oh God which way which
way which way tell me Tommy magical
magical map
Tommy you're not helping me at all where
the hell am I there's another picture hi
what the hell where am I
oh I remember this oh these um ah there
we go
I've had to page you happy for me look
it's yamimash man I do not remember all
these pictures being here before hell is
going on okay I think I think I'm
approaching the you mad bro hallway
still haven't seen plenty yet there's
another picture oh my god bad bro is
this the you mad bro Jorge legs off
printing now
that's a good idea oh this door is all
aah oh my god wish me quit Wow the flip
Wow technique worked on slender do
shut up Wade yeah you're such a douche
all right try that again now they can't
even hear you because my my microphone
is really close so I turned down the
recording volume cuz it's just time for
me to talk
oh so sensually on another way cuz that
didn't seem like a good way to go
the you mad bro hallway I don't even
know it's like everything's so
ass-backwards in this map like by far
there's got to be the most confusing of
all the maps I've got a map here and I
have no idea where I'm going
okay ah my first page that's not right
there's supposed to be what wait hang on
I'll get that one in a second but
there's aa what okay never mind I'm
going back okay my first page where I'm
going oh wait no it's cuz all the map
spawns are randomizing this one oh my
ding ding dong yeah we heard that song
yeah hey I found another page you have
yeah guy here hey always look back I
don't think that's I don't think that's
a good technic
okay I found two pages which means four
lines of the poem and then I'm gonna
just carry on my wayward son there'll be
peace when you are done lay your weary
head to rest don't you cry no more love
Slendy I didn't know that was a tender
home from Slenderman
alright I'm lost again no idea where I'm
going I don't even think I'm on the
right way it's just ah but could this be
easy so this this was meant to be
difficult in something ah save me save
you save e-letter man's gonna start
appearing soon
[Music]
scoot this way huh wear the helmet this
isn't right this isn't right at all this
is absolutely wrong wear that okay this
all hello found another okay slow
painful death
damn right ah that's the you mad throw
hallway I found it again I'm definitely
not mad bra their pace head look it's DJ
more fire hi buddy
aha Oh page he's coming for me
I'm coming oh boy right there Swift whoa
wow wow wow
[ __ ] ow why isn't he
okay thank you God he was like right up
in my grill
[Music]
is that new I hear like a crushing sound
in my ears oh that what happened there
is my model kept I felt like my model is
being pushed has like one last try if I
can't get this then I suck at slender
yeah I'm pretty sure that's already
that's already a given I suck at slender
this was difficult maybe it's cuz I have
absolutely no idea
[Music]
ah
hmm Frank red are in the wrong spot
whoo all right I like to eat my eggs
with Frank's redhot cuz that way see
better always look back Fuu hey beer
taste they're not bad yeah no no can you
guys even see that I don't even know but
soon camera weights being a douche over
here Wade stop being a douche topic doc
baby would never stop being a douche not
seen that seems like you I believe that
the serious business Wade slender is so
scary
I feel like I'm missing pages all over
the place because the rooms are so
convoluted in this game that I keep
running around and just random circles
no idea where I am or why I'm here
story of my life though ah here's
another page I'm up to eight again
are you proud of me wait no there's its
lines this time you got to get oh hello
hey buddy there's on eight of eight
if there's sixteen lines and then you
gotta get yeah good I can't I don't push
me Slendy don't push me sharp blade huh
not again I thought I felt my character
model being pushed ah I do now you gone
now haha
[Music]
no we're way by a little worried what
okay there's one in here right right
right right
hi ha ha ha I got your page getting out
of here with you know where you are turn
my head you big ugly mugs in my face of
course of course I'm gonna be a little
freaked out
given that you are so hideously ugly ha
ha 14 of stop
is there an image well I just need to
find one more one more
burner I'm gonna win
[Music]
alright let me read the poem at least I
got all pages death Grubman Oh should I
travel through the woods or should I not
wishing I would for above me lurks
within the trees no one could hear my
deathly screams the palest man the
blackest suit bigger than the tallest
brute six black arms will grab you up or
stalk you till you just give up a top
hat bears upon his head makes your soul
fill up with dread he takes you when you
least expect boil you up and eat your
neck you leave your body not to eat but
staple your corpse on a tree that
doesn't rhyme fear the man the slender
man for he can do what no one can by
Roston am irani thank you okay hot dip
for now I got all pages oh right there's
the exit I don't need to go back I was
really close so thank you all so much
for watching click the annotation for
videos and I've done
check out the livestream today soon
after this video get the least so thank
you again for watching and I'll see you
[Music]